PROFESSOR: Well, last time Gerry
really let the cat out
of the bag.
He introduced the idea
of assignment.
Assignment and state.
And as we started to see, the
implications of introducing
assignment and state into the
language are absolutely
frightening.
First of all, the substitution
model of
evaluation breaks down.
And we have to use this much
more complicated environment
model and this very mechanistic
thing with
diagrams, even to say what
statements in the programming
language mean.
And that's not a mere
technical point.
See, it's not that we had this
particular substitution model
and, well, it doesn't quite
work, so we have to do
something else.
It's that nothing like the
substitution model can work.
Because suddenly, a variable
is not just something that
stands for a value.
A variable now has to somehow
specify a place
that holds a value.
And the value that's in
that place can change.
Or for instance, an expression
like f of x might have a side
effect in it.
So if we say f of x and it has
some value, and then later we
say f of x again, we might
get a different value
depending on the order.
So suddenly, we have to think
not only about values but
about time.
And then things like pairs are
no longer just their CARs and
their CDRs.
A pair now is not quite its CAR
and its CDR. It's rather
its identity.
So a pair has identity.
It's an object.
And two pairs that have the same
CAR and CDR might be the
same or different, because
suddenly we have to worry
about sharing.
So all of these things enter
as soon as we introduce
assignment.
See, this is a really far cry
from where we started with
substitution.
It's a technically harder way
of looking at things because
we have to think more
mechanistically about our
programming language.
We can't just think about
it as mathematics.
It's philosophically harder,
because suddenly there are all
these funny issues about what
does it mean that something
changes or that two things
are the same.
And also, it's programming
harder, because as Gerry
showed last time, there are all
these bugs having to do
with bad sequencing and aliasing
that just don't exist
in a language where we don't
worry about objects.
Well, how'd we get
into this mess?
Remember what we did, the reason
we got into this is
because we were looking to
build modular systems. We
wanted to build systems that
fall apart into chunks that
seem natural.
So for instance, we want to take
a random number generator
and package up the state of that
random number generator
inside of it so that we can
separate the idea of picking
random numbers from the general
Monte Carlo strategy
of estimating something and
separate that from the
particular way that you work
with random numbers in that
formula developed by
Cesaro for pi.
And similarly, when we go off
and construct some models of
things, if we go off and model
a system that we see in the
real world, we'd like our
program to break into natural
pieces, pieces that mirror the
parts of the system that we
see in the real world.
So for example, if we look at
a digital circuit, we say,
gee, there's a circuit and
it has a piece and
it has another piece.
And these different pieces
sort of have identity.
They have state.
And the state sits
on these wires.
And we think of this piece as
an object that's different
from that as an object.
And when we watch the system
change, we think about a
signal coming in here and
changing a state that might be
here and going here and
interacting with a state that
might be stored there,
and so on and so on.
So what we'd like is we'd like
to build in the computer
systems that fall into pieces
that mirror our view of
reality, of the way that the
actual systems we're modeling
seem to fall into pieces.
Well, maybe the reason that
building systems like this
seems to introduce such
technical complications has
nothing to do with computers.
See, maybe the real reason that
we pay such a price to
write programs that mirror our
view of reality is that we
have the wrong view
of reality.
See, maybe time is just
an illusion, and
nothing ever changes.
See, for example, if I take this
chalk, and we say, gee,
this is an object and
it has a state.
At each moment it has a position
and a velocity.
And if we do something,
that state can change.
But if you studied any
relativity, for instance, you
know that you don't think of
the path of that chalk as
something that goes on
instant by instant.
It's more insightful to think
of that whole chalk's
existence as a path
in space-time.
that's all splayed out.
There aren't individual
positions and velocities.
There's just its unchanging
existence in space-time.
Similarly, if we look at this
electrical system, if we
imagine this electrical system
is implementing some sort of
signal processing system, the
signal processing engineer who
put that thing together doesn't
think of it as, well,
at each instance there's
a voltage coming in.
And that translates
into something.
And that affects the state over
here, which changes the
state over here.
Nobody putting together a
signal processing system
thinks about it like that.
Instead, you say there's
this signal that's
splayed out over time.
And if this is acting as a
filter, this whole thing
transforms this whole thing for
some sort of other output.
You don't think of it as what's
happening instant by
instant as the state
of these things.
And somehow you think of this
box as a whole thing, not as
little pieces sending messages
of state to each other at
particular instants.
Well, today we're going to
look at another way to
decompose systems that's more
like the signal processing
engineer's view of the world
than it is like thinking about
objects that communicate
sending messages.
That's called stream
processing.
And we're going to start by
showing how we can make our
programs more uniform and see
a lot more commonality if we
throw out of these programs
what you might say is an
inordinate concern with
worrying about time.
Let me start by comparing
two procedures.
The first one does this.
We imagine that there's
a tree.
Say there's a tree
of integers.
It's a binary tree.
So it looks like this.
And there's integers in
each of the nodes.
And what we would like to
compute is for each odd number
sitting here, we'd like to find
the square and then sum
up all those squares.
Well, that should be a familiar
kind of thing.
There's a recursive strategy
for doing it.
We look at each leaf, and
either it's going to
contribute the square of
the number if it's odd
or 0 if it's even.
And then recursively, we can say
at each tree, the sum of
all of them is the sum coming
from the right branch and the
left branch, and recursively
down through the nodes.
And that's a familiar way of
thinking about programming.
Let's actually look at
that on the slide.
We say to sum the odd squares
in a tree, well, there's a
test. Either it's a leaf node,
and we're going to check to
see if it's an integer, and then
either it's odd, in which
we take the square,
or else it's 0.
And then the sum of the whole
thing is the sum coming from
the left branch and
the right branch.
OK, well, let me contrast that
with a second problem.
Suppose I give you an integer
n, and then some function to
compute of the first of each
integer in 1 through n.
And then I want to collect
together in a list all those
function values that satisfy
some property.
That's a general
kind of thing.
Let's say to be specific, let's
imagine that for each
integer, k, we're
going to compute
the k Fibonacci number.
And then we'll see which of
those are odd and assemble
those into a list.
So here's a procedure
that does that.
Find the odd Fibonacci numbers
among the first n.
And here is a standard loop the
way we've been writing it.
This is a recursion.
It's a loop on k, and says if
k is bigger than n, it's the
empty list. Otherwise we compute
the k-th Fibonacci
number, call that f.
If it's odd, we CONS it on
to the list starting
with the next one.
And otherwise, we just
take the next one.
And this is the standard
way we've been
writing iterative loops.
And we start off calling
that loop with 1.
OK, so there are
two procedures.
Those procedures look
very different.
They have very different
structures.
Yet from a certain point of
view, those procedures are
really doing very much
the same thing.
So if I was talking like a
signal processing engineer,
what I might say is that the
first procedure enumerates the
leaves of a tree.
And then we can think of a
signal coming out of that,
which is all the leaves.
We'll filter them to see which
ones are odd, put them through
some kind of filter.
We'll then put them through
a kind of transducer.
And for each one of those
things, we'll take the square.
And then we'll accumulate
all of those.
We'll accumulate them by
sticking them together with
addition starting from 0.
That's the first program.
The second program, I can
describe in a very, very
similar way.
I'll say, we'll enumerate the
numbers on this interval, for
the interval 1 through n.
We'll, for each one, compute the
Fibonacci number, put them
through a transducer.
We'll then take the result
of that, and we'll
filter it for oddness.
And then we'll take those and
put them into an accumulator.
This time we'll build up a list,
so we'll accumulate with
CONS starting from
the empty list.
So this way of looking at the
program makes the two seem
very, very similar.
The problem is that that
commonality is completely
obscured when we look at the
procedures we wrote.
Let's go back and look at some
odd squares again, and say
things like, where's
the enumerator?
Where's the enumerator
in this program?
Well, it's not in one place.
It's a little bit in this
leaf-node test,
which is going to stop.
It's a little bit in the
recursive structure of the
thing itself.
Where's the accumulator?
The accumulator isn't
in one place either.
It's partly in this 0 and
partly in this plus.
It's not there as a thing
that we can look at.
Similarly, if we look at odd
Fibs, that's also, in some
sense, an enumerator and
an accumulator, but
it looks very different.
Because partly, the enumerator
is here in this greater than
sign in the test. And partly
it's in this whole recursive
structure in the loop, and
the way that we call it.
And then similarly, that's also
mixed up in there with
the accumulator, which is partly
over there and partly
over there.
So these very, very natural
pieces, these very natural
boxes here don't appear in our
programs. Because they're kind
of mixed up.
The programs don't chop things
up in the right way.
Going back to this fundamental
principle of computer science
that in order to control
something, you need the name
of it, we don't really have
control over thinking about
things this way because we don't
have our hands in them
explicitly.
We don't have a good language
for talking about them.
Well, let's invent an
appropriate language in which
we can build these pieces.
The key to the language is these
guys, is what is these
things I called signals?
What are these things that
are flying on the
arrows between the boxes?
Well, those things are going to
be data structures called
streams. That's going
to be the key to
inventing this language.
What's a stream?
Well, a stream is, like
anything else, a data
abstraction.
So I should tell you what
its selectors and
constructors are.
For a stream, we're going to
have one constructor that's
called CONS-stream.
CONS-stream is going to put two
things together to form a
thing called a stream.
And then to extract things from
the stream, we're going
to have a selector called
the head of the stream.
So if I have a stream, I
can take its head or I
can take its tail.
And remember, I have to tell you
George's contract here to
tell you what the axioms
are that relate these.
And it's going to be for any
x and y, if I form the
CONS-stream and take the head,
the head of CONS-stream of x
and y is going to be x and the
tail of CONS-stream of x and y
is going to be y.
So those are the constructor,
two selectors for
streams, and an axiom.
There's something fishy here.
So you might notice that these
are exactly the axioms for
CONS, CAR, and CDR. If instead
of writing CONS-stream I wrote
CONS and I said head was the
CAR and tail was the CDR,
those are exactly the
axioms for pairs.
And in fact, there's
another thing here.
We're going to have a thing
called the-empty-stream, which
is like the-empty-list.
So why am I introducing
this terminology?
Why don't I just keep talking
about pairs and lists?
Well, we'll see.
For now, if you like, why don't
you just pretend that
streams really are just a
terminology for lists.
And we'll see in a little while
why we want to keep this
extra abstraction layer and
not just call them lists.
OK, now that we have streams, we
can start constructing the
pieces of the language to
operate on streams. And there
are a whole bunch of very useful
things that we could
start making.
For instance, we'll make our map
box to take a stream, s,
and a procedure, and to generate
a new stream which
has as its elements the
procedure applied to all the
successive elements of s.
In fact, we've seen
this before.
This is the procedure map
that we did with lists.
And you see it's exactly map,
except we're testing for
empty-stream.
Oh, I forgot to mention that.
Empty-stream is like the null
test. So if it's empty, we
generate the empty stream.
Otherwise, we form a new stream
whose first element is
the procedure applied to the
head of the stream, and whose
rest is gotten by mapping along
with the procedure down
the tail of the stream.
So that looks exactly like
the map procedure
we looked at before.
Here's another useful thing.
Filter, this is our
filter box.
We're going to have a predicate
and a stream.
We're going to make a new stream
that consists of all
the elements of the
original one
that satisfy the predicate.
That's case analysis.
When there's nothing
in the stream, we
return the empty stream.
We test the predicate on
the head of the stream.
And if it's true, we add the
head of the stream onto the
result of filtering the
tail of the stream.
And otherwise, if that predicate
was false, we just
filter the tail of the stream.
Right, so there's filter.
Let me run through a couple
more rather quickly.
They're all in the book and
you can look at them.
Let me just flash through.
Here's accumulate.
Accumulate takes a way of
combining things and an
initial value in a stream and
sticks them all together.
If the stream's empty, it's
just the initial value.
Otherwise, we combine the head
of the stream with the result
of accumulating the tail of the
stream starting from the
initial value.
So that's what I'd use to add
up everything in the stream.
I'd accumulate with plus.
How would I enumerate the
leaves of a tree?
Well, if the tree is just a leaf
itself, I make something
which only has that
node in it.
Otherwise, I append together the
stuff of enumerating the
left branch and the
right branch.
And then append here is like the
ordinary append on lists.
You can look at that.
That's analogous to the
ordinary procedure for
appending two lists.
How would I enumerate
an interval?
This will take two integers, low
and high, and generate a
stream of the integers going
from low to high.
And we can make a whole
bunch of pieces.
So that's a little language of
talking about streams. Once we
have streams, we can build
things for manipulating them.
Again, we're making
a language.
And now we can start expressing
things in this language.
Here's our original procedure
for summing the odd
squares in a tree.
And you'll notice it looks
exactly now like the block
diagram, like the signal
processing block diagram.
So to sum the odd squares in a
tree, we enumerate the leaves
of the tree.
We filter that for oddness.
We map that for squareness.
And we accumulate the result
of that using addition,
starting from 0.
So we can see the pieces
that we wanted.
Similarly, the Fibonacci one,
how do we get the odd Fibs?
Well, we enumerate the interval
from 1 to n, we map
along that, computing the
Fibonacci of each one.
We filter the result of
those for oddness.
And we accumulate all of that
stuff using CONS starting from
the empty-list.
OK, what's the advantage
of this?
Well, for one thing, we now have
pieces that we can start
mixing and matching.
So for instance, if I wanted to
change this, if I wanted to
compute the squares of the
integers and then filter them,
all I need to do is pick up a
standard piece like this in
that square and put it in.
Or if we wanted to do this whole
Fibonacci computation on
the leaves of a tree rather than
a sequence, all I need to
do is replace this enumerator
with that one.
See, the advantage of this
stream processing is that
we're establishing--
this is one of the big themes
of the course--
we're establishing conventional
interfaces that
allow us to glue things
together.
Things like map and filter are
a standard set of components
that we can start using for
pasting together programs in
all sorts of ways.
It allows us to see the
commonality of programs.
I just ought to mention, I've
only showed you two
procedures.
But let me emphasize that this
way of putting things together
with maps, filters,
and accumulators
is very, very general.
It's the generate and test
paradigm for programs. And as
an example of that, Richard
Waters, who was at MIT when he
was a graduate student, as part
of his thesis research
went and analyzed a large chunk
of the IBM scientific
subroutine library, and
discovered that about 60% of
the programs in it could be
expressed exactly in terms
using no more than what
we've put here--
map, filter, and accumulate.
All right, let's take a break.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: It seems like the
essence of this whole thing is
just that you have a very
uniform, simple data structure
to work with, the stream.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The essence is that you, again,
it's this sense of
conventional interfaces.
So you can start putting a
lot of things together.
And the stream is as you say,
the uniform data structure
that supports that.
This is very much like
APL, by the way.
APL is very much the same idea,
except in APL, instead
of this stream, you have
arrays and vectors.
And a lot of the power of APL is
exactly the same reason of
the power of this.
OK, thank you.
Let's take a break.
All right.
We've been looking at ways of
organizing computations using
streams. What I want to do now
is just show you two somewhat
more complicated examples
of that.
Let's start by thinking about
the following kind of utility
procedure that will
come in useful.
Suppose I've got a stream.
And the elements of this stream
are themselves streams.
So the first thing
might be 1, 2, 3.
So I've got a stream.
And each element of the stream
is itself a stream.
And what I'd like to do is build
a stream that collects
together all of the elements,
pulls all of the elements out
of these sub-streams and
strings them all
together in one thing.
So just to show you the use of
this language, how easy it is,
call that flatten.
And I can define to flatten this
stream of streams. Well,
what is that?
That's just an accumulation.
I want to accumulate
using append, by
successively appending.
So I accumulate using append
streams, starting with
the-empty-stream down that
stream of streams.
OK, so there's an example of how
you can start using these
higher order things to do some
interesting operations.
In fact, there's another
useful thing
that I want to do.
I want to define a procedure
called flat-map, flat map of
some function and a stream.
And what this is going
to do is f will
be a stream of elements.
f is going to be a function that
for each element in the
stream produces another
stream.
And what I want to do is take
all of the elements and all of
those streams and combine
them together.
So that's just going to be the
flatten of map f down s.
Each time I apply f to an
element of s, I get a stream.
If I map it all the way down, I
get a stream of streams, and
I'll flatten that.
Well, I want to use that to
show you a new way to do a
familiar kind of problem.
The problem's going to be like a
lot of problems you've seen,
although maybe not this
particular one.
I'm going to give you
an integer, n.
And the problem is going to be
find all pairs and integers i
and j, between 0 and i, with j
less than i, up to n, such
that i plus j is prime.
So for example, if n equals 6,
let's make a little table
here, i and j and i plus j.
So for, say, i equals 2 and
j equals 1, I'd get 3.
And for i equals 3, I could
have j equals 2, and that
would be 5.
And 4 and 1 would be 5 and so
on, up until i goes to 6.
And what I'd like to return is
to produce a stream of all the
triples like this, let's
say i, j, and i plus j.
So for each n, I want to
generate this stream.
OK, well, that's easy.
Let's build it up.
We start like this.
We're going to say for
each i, we're going
to generate a stream.
For each i in the interval 1
through n, we're going to
generate a stream.
What's that stream
going to be?
We're going to start by
generating all the pairs.
So for each i, we're going to
generate, for each j in the
interval 1 to i minus 1, we'll
generate the pair, or the list
with two elements i and j.
So we map along the interval,
generating the pairs.
And for each i, that generates
a stream of pairs.
And we flatmap it.
Now we have all the pairs
i and j, such that i
is less than j.
So that builds that.
Now we're got to test them.
Well, we take that thing we just
built, the flatmap, and
we filter it to see
whether the i--
see, we had an i and a j.
i was the first thing in the
list, j was the second thing
in the list. So we have a
predicate which says in that
list of two elements
is the sum of the
CAR and the CDR prime.
And we filter that collection
of pairs we just built.
So those are the
pairs we want.
Now we go ahead and we take the
result of that filter and
we map along it, generating the
list i and j and i plus j.
And that's our procedure
prime-sum-pairs.
And then just to flash it up,
here's the whole procedure.
A map, a filter, a flatmap.
There's the whole thing,
even though this isn't
particularly readable.
It's just expanding
that flatmap.
So there's an example which
illustrates the general point
that nested loops in this
procedure start looking like
compositions of flatmaps of
flatmaps of flatmaps of maps
and things.
So not only can we enumerate
individual things, but by
using flatmaps, we can do what
would correspond to nested
loops in most other languages.
Of course, it's pretty awful to
keep writing these flatmaps
of flatmaps of flatmaps.
Prime-sum-pairs you saw looked
fairly complicated, even
though the individual
pieces were easy.
So what you can do, if you
like, is introduced some
syntactic sugar that's
called collect.
And collect is just an
abbreviation for that nest of
flatmaps and filters arranged
in that particular way.
Here's prime-sum-pairs again,
written using collect.
It says to find all those pairs,
I'm going to collect
together a result, which is the
list i, j, and i plus j,
that's going to be generated as
i runs through the interval
from 1 to n and as j runs
through the interval from 1 to
i minus 1, such that
i plus j is prime.
So I'm not going to say what
collect does in general.
You can look at that by looking
at it in the book.
But pretty much, you can see
that the pieces of this are
the pieces of that original
procedure I wrote.
And this collect is just some
syntactic sugar for
automatically generating that
nest of flatmaps and flatmaps.
OK, well, let me do one more
example that shows you the
same kind of thing.
Here's a very famous problem
that's used to illustrate a
lot of so-called backtracking
computer algorithms. This is
the eight queens problem.
This is a chess board.
And the eight queens problem
says, find a way to put down
eight queens on a chess board
so that no two are attacking
each other.
And here's a particular
solution to the
eight queens problem.
So I have to make sure to put
down queens so that no two are
in the same row or the
same column or sit
along the same diagonal.
Now, there's sort of a standard
way of doing that.
Well, first we need
to do is below the
surface, at George's level.
We have to find some way to
represent a board, and
represent positions.
And we'll not worry
about that.
But let's assume that there's
a predicate called safe.
And what safe is going to do is
going to say given that I
have a bunch of queens down on
the chess board, is it OK to
put a queen in this
particular spot?
So safe is going to take
a row and a column.
That's going to be a place where
I'm going to try and put
down the next queen, and
the rest of positions.
And what safe will say is given
that I already have
queens down in these positions,
is it safe to put
another queen down in that
row and that column?
And let's not worry
about that.
That's George's problem. and
it's not hard to write.
You just have to check whether
this thing contains any things
on that row or that column
or in that diagonal.
Now, how would you organize
the program given that?
And there's sort of a
traditional way to organize it
called backtracking.
And it says, well, let's think
about all the ways of putting
the first queen down in
the first column.
There are eight ways.
Well, let's say try
the first column.
Try column 1, row 1.
These branches are going to
represent the possibilities at
each level.
So I'll try and put a queen
down in the first column.
And now given that it's in the
first column, I'll try and put
the next queen down in
the first column.
I'll try and put the first
queen, the one in the first
column, down in the first row.
I'm sorry.
And then given that, we'll
put the next queen down
in the first row.
And that's no good.
So I'll back up to here.
And I'll say, oh, can I put the
first queen down in the
second row?
Well, that's no good.
Oh, can I put it down
in the third row?
Well, that's good.
Well, now can I put the
next queen down
in the first column?
Well, I can't visualize this
chess board anymore, but I
think that's right.
And I try the next one.
And at each place, I go as far
down this tree as I can.
And I back up.
If I get down to here and find
no possibilities below there,
I back all the way up to here,
and now start again generating
this sub-tree.
And I sort of walk around.
And finally, if I ever manage to
get all the way down, I've
found a solution.
So that's a typical sort of
paradigm that's used a lot in
AI programming.
It's called backtracking
search.
And it's really unnecessary.
You saw me get confused when I
was visualizing this thing.
And you see the complication.
This is a complicated
thing to say.
Why is it complicated?
Its because somehow this program
is too inordinately
concerned with time.
It's too much--
I try this one, and I try this
one, and I go back to the last
possibility.
And that's a complicated
thing.
If I stop worrying about time
so much, then there's a much
simpler way to describe this.
It says, let's imagine that I
have in my hands the tree down
to k minus 1 levels.
See, suppose I had in my hands
all possible ways to put down
queens in the first k columns.
Suppose I just had that.
Let's not worry about
how we get it.
Well, then, how do
I extend that?
How do I find all possible ways
to put down queens in the
next column?
It's really easy.
For each of these positions I
have, I think about putting
down a queen in each row
to make the next thing.
And then for each one I put
down, I filter those by the
ones that are safe.
So instead of thinking about
this tree as generated step by
step, suppose I had
it all there.
And to extend it from level k
minus 1 to level k, I just
need to extend each thing in
all possible ways and only
keep the ones that are safe.
And that will give me
the tree to level k.
And that's a recursive strategy
for solving the eight
queens problem.
All right, well, let's
look at it.
To solve the eight queens
problem on a board of some
specified size, we write
a sub-procedure called
fill-columns.
Fill-columns is going to
put down queens up
through column k.
And here's the pattern
of the recursion.
I'm going to call fill-columns
with the size eventually.
So fill-columns says how to put
down queens safely in the
first k columns of this chess
board with a size number of
rows in it.
If k is equal to 0, well,
then I don't have to
put anything down.
So my solution is just
an empty chess board.
Otherwise, I'm going
to do some stuff.
And I'm going to use collect.
And here's the collect.
I find all ways to put
down queens in the
first k minus 1 columns.
And this was just
what I set for.
Imagine I have this tree down
to k minus 1 levels.
And then I find all ways of
trying a row, that's just each
of the possible rows.
They're size rows, so that's
enumerate interval.
And now what I do is I collect
together the new row I'm going
to try and column k with
the rest of the queens.
I adjoin a position.
This is George's problem.
An adjoined position
is like safe.
It's a thing that takes a row
and a column and the rest of
the positions and makes a
new position collection.
So I adjoin a position of a new
row and a new column to
the rest of the queens, where
the rest of the queens runs
through all possible ways
of solving the problem
in k minus 1 columns.
And the new row runs through all
possible rows such that it
was safe to put one there.
And that's the whole program.
There's the whole procedure.
Not only that, that doesn't just
solve the eight queens
problem, it gives you
all solutions to the
eight queens problem.
When you're done, you
have a stream.
And the elements of that stream
are all possible ways
of solving that problem.
Why is that simpler?
Well, we threw away the whole
idea that this is some process
that happens in time
with state.
And we just said it's a whole
collection of stuff.
And that's why it's simpler.
We've changed our view.
Remember, that's where
we started today.
We've changed our view of what
it is we're trying to model.
we stop modeling things that
evolve in time and have steps
and have state.
And instead, we're trying to
model this global thing like
the whole flight of the
chalk, rather than its
state at each instant.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: It looks to me like
backtracking would be
searching for the first solution
it can find, whereas
this recursive search would be
looking for all solutions.
And it seems that if you have a
large enough area to search,
that the second is going
to become impossible.
PROFESSOR: OK, the answer to
that question is the whole
rest of this lecture.
It's exactly the
right question.
And without trying to anticipate
the lecture too
much, you should start being
suspicious at this point, and
exactly those kinds
of suspicions.
It's wonderful, but isn't it
so terribly inefficient?
That's where we're going.
So I won't answer now, but
I'll answer later.
OK, let's take a break.
Well, by now you should be
starting to get suspicious.
See, I've showed your this
simple, elegant way of putting
programs together, very unlike
these other traditional
programs that sum the odd
squares or compute the odd
Fibonacci numbers.
Very unlike these programs that
mix up the enumerator and
the filter and the
accumulator.
And by mixing it up, we don't
have all of these wonderful
conceptual advantages of these
streams pieces, these
wonderful mix and match
components for putting
together lots and lots
of programs.
On the other hand, most of the
programs you've seen look like
these ugly ones.
Why's that?
Can it possibly be that computer
scientists are so
obtuse that they don't notice
that if you'd merely did this
thing, then you can get this
great programming elegance?
There's got to be a catch.
And it's actually pretty easy
to see what the catch is.
Let's think about the
following problem.
Suppose I tell you to find the
second prime between 10,000
and 1 million, or if your
computer's larger, say between
10,000 and 100 billion,
or something.
And you say, oh, that's easy.
I can do that with a stream.
All I do is I enumerate
the interval
from 10,000 to 1 million.
So I get all those integers
I filter them for prime-ness, so
test all of them and see if
they're prime.
And I take the second element.
That's the head of the tail.
Well, that's clearly
pretty ridiculous.
We'd not even have room in the
machine to store the integers
in the first place, much
less to test them.
And then I only want
the second one.
See, the power of this
traditional programming style
is exactly its weakness, that
we're mixing up the
enumerating and the testing
and the accumulating.
So we don't do it all.
So the very thing that makes
it conceptually ugly is the
very thing that makes
it efficient.
It's this mixing up.
So it seems that all I've done
this morning so far is just
confuse you.
I showed you this wonderful
way that programming might
work, except that it doesn't.
Well, here's where the wonderful
thing happens.
It turns out in this game that
we really can have our cake
and eat it too.
And what I mean by that is
that we really can write
stream programs exactly like the
ones I wrote and arrange
things so that when the machine
actually runs, it's as
efficient as running this
traditional programming style
that mixes up the generation
and the test.
Well, that sounds
pretty magic.
The key to this is that
streams are not lists.
We'll see this carefully in a
second, but for now, let's
take a look at that
slide again.
The image you should have here
of this signal processing
system is that what's going to
happen is there's this box
that has the integers
sitting in it.
And there's this filter that's
connected to it and it's
tugging on them.
And then there's someone who's
tugging on this stuff saying
what comes out of the filter.
And the image you should have
is that someone says, well,
what's the first prime, and
tugs on this filter.
And the filter tugs
on the integers.
And you look only at that much,
and then say, oh, I
really wanted the second one.
What's the second prime?
And that no computation gets
done except when you tug on
these things.
Let me try that again.
This is a little device.
This is a little stream machine
invented by Eric
Grimson who's been teaching
this course at MIT.
And the image is here's a stream
of stuff, like a whole
bunch of the integers.
And here's some processing
elements.
And if, say, it's filter of
filter of map, or something.
And if I really tried to
implement that with streams as
lists, what I'd say is, well,
I've got this list of things,
and now I do the first filter.
So do all this processing.
And I take this and I process
and I process and I process
and I process.
And now I'm got this
new stream.
Now I take that result
in my hand someplace.
And I put that through
the second one.
And I process the whole thing.
And there's this new stream.
And then I take the result and
I put it all the way through
this one the same way.
That's what would happen to
these stream programs if
streams were just lists.
But in fact, streams aren't
lists, they're streams. And
the image you should have
is something a little
bit more like this.
I've got these gadgets connected
up by this data
that's flowing out of them.
And here's my original source
of the streams. It might be
starting to generate
the integers.
And now, what happens
if I want a result?
I tug on the end here.
And this element says, gee,
I need some more data.
So this one comes here
and tugs on that one.
And it says, gee, I need
some more data.
And this one tugs on this
thing, which might be a
filter, and says, gee, I
need some more data.
And only as much of this thing
at the end here gets generated
as I tugged.
And only as much of this stuff
goes through the processing
units as I'm pulling
on the end I need.
That's the image you should have
of the difference between
implementing what we're actually
going to do and if
streams were lists.
Well, how do we make
this thing?
I hope you have the image.
The trick is how to make it.
We want to arrange for a stream
to be a data structure
that computes itself
incrementally, an on-demand
data structure.
And the basic idea is, again,
one of the very basic ideas
that we're seeing throughout
the whole course.
And that is that there's not
a firm distinction between
programs and data.
So what a stream is going to be
is simultaneously this data
structure that you think of,
like the stream of the leaves
of this tree.
But at the same time, it's
going to be a very clever
procedure that has the method
of computing in it.
Well, let me try this.
It's going to turn out that we
don't need any more mechanism.
We already have everything we
need simply from the fact that
we know how to handle
procedures
as first-class objects.
Well, let's go back
to the key.
The key is, remember, we
had these operations.
CONS-stream and head and tail.
When I started, I said you can
think about this as CONS and
think about this as CAR and
think about that as
CDR, but it's not.
Now, let's look at what
they really are.
Well, CONS-stream of x and y is
going to be an abbreviation
for the following thing.
CONS form a pair, ordinary CONS,
of x to a thing called
delay of y.
And before I explain that, let
me go and write the rest. The
head of a stream is going
to be just the CAR.
And the tail of a stream is
going to be a thing called
force the CDR of the stream.
Now let me explain this.
Delay is going to be a
special magic thing.
What delay does is take an
expression and produce a
promise to compute
that expression
when you ask for it.
It doesn't do any computation
here.
It just gives you
a rain check.
It produces a promise.
And CONS-stream says I'm going
to put together in a pair x
and a promise to compute y.
Now, if I want the head, that's
just the CAR that I put
in the pair.
And the key is that the
tail is going to be--
force calls in that promise.
Tail says, well, take
that promise and now
call in that promise.
And then we compute
that thing.
That's how this is
going to work.
That's what CONS-stream, head,
and tail really are.
Now, let's see how this works.
And we'll go through this
fairly carefully.
We're going to see how this
works in this example of
computing the second prime
between 10,000 and a million.
OK, so we start off and we
have this expression.
The second prime-- the head of
the tail of the result of
filtering for primality
the integers between
10,000 and 1 million.
Now, what is that?
What that is, that interval
between 10,000 and 1 million,
well, if you trace through
enumerate interval, there
builds a CONS-stream.
And the CONS-stream is the CONS
of 10,000 to a promise to
compute the integers between
10,001 and 1 million.
So that's what this
expression is.
Here I'm using the substitution
model.
And we can use the substitution
model because we
don't have side effects
and state.
So I have CONS of 10,000 to a
promise to compute the rest of
the integers.
So only one integer, so
far, got enumerated.
Well, I'm going to filter that
thing for primality.
Again, you go back and look
at the filter code.
What the filter will first
do is test the head.
So in this case, the filter will
test 10,000 and say, oh,
10,000's not prime.
Therefore, what I have
to do recursively
is filter the tail.
And what's the tail of it, well,
that's the tail of this
pair with a promise in it.
Tail now comes in and says,
well, I'm going to force that.
I'm going to force that promise,
which means now I'm
going to compute the integers
between 10,001 and 1 million.
OK, so this filter now
is looking at that.
That enumerate itself, well, now
we're back in the original
enumerate situation.
The enumerate is the CONS of the
first thing, 10,001, onto
a promise to compute the rest.
So now the primality filter is
going to go look at 10,001.
It's going to decide if
it likes that or not.
It turns out 10,001
isn't prime.
So it'll force it again
and again and again.
And finally, I think the first
prime it hits is 10,009.
And at that point, it'll stop.
And that will be the first
prime, and then eventually,
it'll need the second prime.
So at that point, it
will go again.
So you see what happens is that
no more gets generated
than you actually need.
That enumerator is not going to
generate any more integers
than the filter asks it for as
it's pulling in things to
check for primality.
And the filter is not going to
generate any more stuff than
you ask it for, which is
the head of the tail.
You see, what's happened is
we've put that mixing of
generation and test into what
actually happens in the
computer, even though that's
not apparently what's
happening from looking
at our programs.
OK, well, that seemed easy.
All of this mechanism got put
into this magic delay.
So you're saying, gee, that must
be where the magic is.
But see there's no magic
there either.
You know what delay is.
Delay on some expression is
just an abbreviation for--
well, what's a promise to
compute an expression?
Lambda of nil, procedure of no
arguments, which is that
expression.
That's what a procedure is.
It says I'm going to compute
an expression.
What's force?
How do I take up a promise?
Well, force of some procedure,
a promise, is just run it.
Done.
So there's no magic
there at all.
Well, what have we done?
We said the old style,
traditional style of
programming is more efficient.
And the stream thing is
more perspicuous.
And we managed to make the
stream procedures run like the
other procedures
by using delay.
And the thing that delay did
for us was to de-couple the
apparent order of events in our
programs from the actual
order of events that happened
in the machine.
That's really what
delay is doing.
That's exactly the
whole point.
We've given up the idea that our
procedures, as they run,
or as we look at them, mirror
some clear notion of time.
And by giving that up, we give
delay the freedom to arrange
the order of events in the
computation the way it likes.
That's the whole idea.
We de-couple the apparent
order of events in our
programs from the actual order
of events in the computer.
OK, well there's one
more detail.
It's just a technical detail,
but it's actually
an important one.
As you run through these
recursive programs unwinding,
you'll see a lot of things that
look like tail of the
tail of the tail.
That's the kind of thing that
would happen as I go CONSing
down a stream all the way.
And if each time I'm doing that,
each time to compute a
tail, I evaluate a procedure
which then has to go
re-compute its tail, and
re-compute its tail and
recompute its tail each time,
you can see that's very
inefficient compared to just
having a list where the
elements are all there, and I
don't have to re-compute each
tail every time I get
the next tail.
So there's one little hack to
slightly change what delay is,
and make it a thing which is--
I'll write it this way.
The actual implementation, delay
is an abbreviation for
this thing, memo-proc
of a procedure.
Memo-proc is a special thing
that transforms a procedure.
What it does is it takes a
procedure of no arguments and
it transforms it into a
procedure that'll only have to
do its computation once.
And what I mean by that is,
you give it a procedure.
The result of memo-proc will be
a new procedure, which the
first time you call it, will
run the original procedure,
remember what result it got, and
then from ever on after,
when you call it, it just
won't have to do the
computation.
It will have cached that
result someplace.
And here's an implementation
of memo-proc.
Once you have the idea, it's
easy to implement.
Memo-proc is this little
thing that has two
little flags in there.
It says, have I already
been run?
And initially it says, no, I
haven't already been run.
And what was the result I got
the last time I was run?
So memo-proc takes a procedure
called proc, and it returns a
new procedure of no arguments.
Proc is supposed to be a
procedure of no arguments.
And it says, oh, if I'm not
already run, then I'm going to
do a sequence of things.
I'm going to compute proc,
I'm going to save that.
I'm going to stash that in
the variable result.
I'm going to make a note to
myself that I've already been
run, and then I'll return
the result.
So that's if you compute it
if it's not already run.
If you call it and it's already
been run, it just
returns the result.
So that's a little clever
hack called memoization.
And in this case, it short
circuits having to re-compute
the tail of the tail of the tail
of the tail of the tail.
So there isn't even that
kind of inefficiency.
And in fact, the streams will
run with pretty much the same
efficiency as the other
programs precisely.
And remember, again, the whole
idea of this is that we've
used the fact that there's no
really good dividing line
between procedures and data.
We've written data structures
that, in fact, are sort of
like procedures.
And what that's allowed us to
do is take an example of a
common control structure,
in this place iteration.
And we've built a data structure
which, since itself
is a procedure, kind of has
this iteration control
structure in it.
And that's really what
streams are.
OK, questions?
AUDIENCE: Your description
of tail-tail-tail, if I
understand it correctly, force
is actually execution of a
procedure, if it's done without
this memo-proc thing.
And you implied that memo-proc
gets around that problem.
Doesn't it only get around it
if tail-tail-tail is always
executing exactly the same--
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's--
sure.
AUDIENCE: I guess I
missed that point.
PROFESSOR: Oh, sure.
I mean the point is--
yeah.
I mean I have to do a
computation to get the answer.
But the point is, once I've
found the tail of the stream,
to get the tail of the tail,
I shouldn't have had to
re-compute the first tail.
See, and if I didn't use
memo-proc, that re-computation
would have been done.
AUDIENCE: I understand now.
AUDIENCE: In one of your
examples, you mentioned that
we were able to use the
substitution model because
there are no side effects.
What if we had a single
processing unit--
if we had a side effect,
if we had a state?
Could we still practically
build the stream model?
PROFESSOR: Maybe.
That's a hard question.
I'm going to talk a little bit
later about the places where
substitution and side effects
don't really mix very well.
But in general, I think the
answer is unless you're very
careful, any amount of side
effect is going to mess up
everything.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I didn't
quite understand
the memo-proc operation.
When do you execute
the lambda?
In other words, when memo-proc
is executed, just this lambda
expression is being generated.
But it's not clear to me
when it's executed.
PROFESSOR: Right.
What memo-proc does-- remember,
the thing that's
going into memo-proc, the thing
proc, is a procedure of
no arguments.
And someday, you're
going to call it.
Memo-proc translates that
procedure into another
procedure of no arguments,
which someday
you're going to call.
That's that lambda.
So here, where I initially
built as my tail of the
stream, say, this procedure
of no arguments, which
someday I'll call.
Instead, I'm going to have
the tail of the stream be
memo-proc of it, which
someday I'll call.
So that lambda of nil, that gets
called when you call the
memo-proc, when you call the
result of that memo-proc,
which would be ordinarily when
you would have called the
original thing that
you set it.
AUDIENCE: OK, the reason I ask
is I had a feeling that when
you call memo-proc, you just
return this lambda.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
When you call memo-proc,
you return the lambda.
You never evaluate the
expression at all, until the
first time that you would
have evaluated it.
AUDIENCE: Do I understand it
right that you actually have
to build the list up, but
the elements of the
list don't get evaluated?
The expressions don't
get evaluated?
But at each stage, you actually
are building a list.
PROFESSOR: That's--
I really should have
said this.
That's a really good point.
No, it's not quite right.
Because what happens is this.
Let me draw this as pairs.
Suppose I'm going to make a
big stream, like enumerate
interval, 1 through 1 billion.
What that is, is a pair with
a 1 and a promise.
That's exactly what it is.
Nothing got built up.
When I go and force this,
and say, what happens?
Well, this thing is now also
recursively a CONS.
So that this promise now is the
next thing, which is a 2
and a promise to do more.
And so on and so on and so on.
So nothing gets built up until
you walk down the stream.
Because what's sitting here is
not the list, but a promise to
generate the list.
And by promise,
technically I mean procedure.
So it doesn't get built up.
Yeah, I should have said
that before this point.
OK.
Thank you.
Let's take a break.